Hallo und herzlich willkommen zum Chaosradio 298. Mein Name ist Marcus Richter
Und ich sitze immer hier und dann sitzen Leute bei mir und wir greifen uns so
ein Thema raus, was gerade so im Schwang ist. Also alle reden darüber,
aber was ist es eigentlich?
Oder von dem wir denken, darüber müsste man eigentlich mal reden und dann bieten
wir so eine Art Einstiegs-, Anfangserklärungs-Hinter-die-Kulissen-Gucken.
Immer dabei ist Constanze Kurz, hallo und guten Tag.
Ja, hallo Marcus.
Eine Sprecherin, die auch zur Presse spricht, des Chaos Computer Clubs,
Autorin bei Netzpolitik.org, wo auch eine zweite Person herkommt,
die heute hier ist, nämlich Ingo Dachwitz. Hallo, guten Tag.
Hallo.
Du bist auch bei Netzpolitik.org und du hast zufälligerweise,
normalerweise sag ich mal erst das Thema und dann, aber hier passt es,
weil du hast ein Buch rausgebracht, das ganz zufälligerweise denselben Titel
trägt wie diese Folge, Digitaler Kolonialismus.
Was das ist, besprechen wir gleich.
Naja, wir müssen ehrlich sein. Jetzt, wo wir aufnehmen, wir wollten ja immer
sagen, wann wir aufnehmen, ist das Buch noch gar nicht erschienen.
Es kommt nämlich Donnerstag.
Wir können uns alle noch drauf freuen, aber wenn der Podcast kommt.
Also heute ist Dienstag. Also man wird wahrscheinlich in späteren Generationen
von vor der letzten Bundestagswahl sprechen.
Wir sind vor der Wahl im Jahr 2025. 25.
Genau. Und dann haben wir noch Lena Ulbricht.
Hallo.
Professorin für Politikwissenschaften an der Uni Hildesheim und auch beim Weizenbaum-Institut
mit als Gastprofessorin.
Was ist eigentlich eine Gastprofessorin?
Das ist eine Person, die eine Professur hat und in irgendeiner Form noch im
Institut mitwirkt, weil sie dort noch Projekte hat.
Okay, verstehe. Hallo und herzlich willkommen. Und du beschäftigst dich auch mit dem Thema?
Ja, unter anderem. Im Prinzip mit Machtbeziehungen in der digitalen Transformation.
Und da spielt Kolonialismus auch eine Rolle.
Und das ist genau, worüber wir heute sprechen wollen. Und das ist ein Thema,
wo ich mich sehr freue, dass wir es heute machen, weil es gibt ja auch in diesem
aktivistisch-netzpolitischen, zivilgesellschaftlichen Kontext gibt es ja,
Hypes wäre das falsche Wort, gibt es Memes oder Themen, die auftauchen,
über die dann immer mehr gesprochen wird. Mal geht das sehr schnell.
Manchmal taucht das so langsam auf. Und ich habe so das Gefühl...
Innerhalb der letzten drei bis fünf Jahre wird über digitaler Kolonialismus
gesprochen und das bezeichnet aber was, über das schon sehr viel länger gesprochen wird.
Und es ist im Digitalen was sehr ähnliches, also was, ich habe immer ein Bild
überlegt sozusagen, womit sind alle Menschen schon mal in Berührung bekommen
und ich glaube, das stärkste Bild ist, worüber wir alle schon mal mindestens
was gehört haben, ist Klamottenproduktion.
Irgendwann ist mal dieses Werk abgebrannt und spätestens dann wusste jeder,
es werden Klamotten sehr billig in armen Ländern produziert und da werden Menschen
ausgenutzt und das sozusagen im weitesten Sinne, dass diese Art von Machtverhältnis
gibt es eben auch im Digitalen und das will ich mir heute mal von euch erklären
lassen, was genau hintersteckt.
Digitaler Kolonialismus, eine Begriffsdefinition. Geht es in einem Satz?
Die globalen Macht- und Ausbeutungsverhältnisse hinter der Digitalisierung,
die kolonial geprägt sind.
Was heißt kolonial geprägt?
Das heißt, dass wir darin, ja, Macht- und Ausbeutungsdynamiken sehen,
die wir eben nicht erst seit kurzem haben, sondern die anknüpfen an dem was
wir im Kolonialismus erlebt haben.
Gemeinhin geht man ja davon aus, oder sagt man so, Kolonialismus war eine historische Periode,
die ging halt vor 500 Jahren los und als die Europäer losgesegelt sind und sozusagen
die Welt unterworfen haben auf brutalste Art und Weise und die endete dann vor 60, 70 Jahren,
als die letzten afrikanischen Staaten die Unabhängigkeit erreicht haben quasi.
Aber der Kolonialismus hörte damit eben gar nicht auf, sondern prägt die Welt
bis heute in globalen Machtstrukturen,
in dem wie unsere Wirtschaft funktioniert und das trifft auch die Digitalisierung.
Also und politisch natürlich auch.
Genau.
Und bei der Digitalisierung sozusagen kann man schön wirklich alle Stufen durchgehen,
die beim Digitalen eine Rolle spielen und das fängt dann an bei den Geräten,
die wir benutzen, um digital umzugehen. Und das hat man vielleicht schon gehört.
Am ehesten ist ab und zu mal in den Nachrichten sozusagen geht es um seltenen Erden.
Also es gibt Rohstoffe, die werden für Digitalgeräte gebraucht.
Die sind halt sehr selten und die findet man vor allen Dingen in Ländern, die arm sind.
Und wie sieht dann da digitaler Kolonialismus aus?
Naja, also ich würde sagen, wenn wir über Rohstoffe sprechen,
ist die Europäische Union arm. Das muss man als erstes mal festhalten, ist die EU arm.
Keine Region auf der Welt hat so wenig Rohstoffe wie die EU.
Außer die Ukraine vielleicht?
Genau, die Ukraine, das merkt man jetzt ja gerade auch in den Auseinandersetzungen
um die Ukraine sozusagen.
Trump fordert Rohstoffe und so weiter. Ja, aber genau, also Europa ist arm an
mineralischen Rohstoffen, aber sie werden eben benötigt für das,
was wir Digitalisierung nennen, für die Energietransition,
also Lithium-Ionen-Akkus sind für das, was da passiert.
Mir fällt jetzt gerade auf, dass man wahrscheinlich bei allen Themen,
die wir heute besprechen können, immer drei Fragen stellen kann,
nämlich warum ist das so?
Warum bleibt das so? Und was kann man dagegen machen?
Und jetzt bei seltenen Erden ist, also ich finde sozusagen der Vergleich mit
Rohstoffen ist, es gibt ja auch Öl in Saudi-Arabien, die sind aber sehr reich damit geworden.
Es gibt Lithium im Kongo, die sind nicht damit reich geworden. Warum nicht?
Also wie ist das dazu gekommen, dass wir diese Situation haben?
Tatsächlich sind koloniale Strukturen auch in politischer Hinsicht geblieben.
Also dass Kobalt in Kongo unter menschenunwürdigen Bedingungen gefördert wird,
ist auch deshalb möglich, weil es sich um eine instabile Region handelt.
Und das ist ein weiteres Erbe des Kolonialismus, dass viele Regionen weltweit
im Prinzip von sehr instabilen gesellschaftlichen Strukturen geprägt sind,
die entstanden sind, als sich Kolonialmächte zurückgezogen haben.
Also im Prinzip ein Wechsel aus autokratischen Regimen, Machtvakuum,
Bürgerkrieg, wo Menschenrechte nicht gewahrt werden, wo es zu wenig Regulierung
gibt, diese nicht implementiert wird, wo sehr hohe Korruption verzeichnet wird.
Und unter solchen Bedingungen sind dann entsprechend die Regierungen häufig
gar nicht fähig, selber,
ich möchte fast nicht sagen, dass sie nicht fähig sind, aber es ist ein politischer
Kontext, in dem es relativ schwierig ist, die Industrie selber in der Hand zu halten,
entweder durch staatliche Unternehmen oder durch eine starke Industrie,
diese ganze Förderung selber vorzunehmen.
Darüber hinaus eben auch eine lange Geschichte von ausbeuterischen Handelsverträgen
oder wie gesagt Korruption, bei der eben westliche Unternehmen oder chinesische
Unternehmen in den Markt drängen,
Lokalregierungen oder Zentralregierungen bestechen und dann hier unreguliert
mehr oder weniger dann an die Ressourcen gelangen.
Also wenn es jetzt so detailliert ist, sag Bescheid, aber wie muss man das vorstellen?
Instabil stelle ich mir politisch instabil vor, das heißt, da wechselt sehr
oft auch die Macht in verschiedenen Fraktionen.
Wie ist das dann mit den Firmen, die das fördern, das Geld machen?
Ist das dann eigentlich sehr stabil und die gucken halt sozusagen,
dass die nächste Regierung auch immer schön irgendwie an der Hand oder am Geldkorb
gehalten wird oder wechselt das auch sehr häufig?
Also vielleicht gehen wir einfach sogar nochmal einen Schritt zurück.
Die koloniale Rohstoffausbeutung im Kongo
Das geht 150 Jahre zurück sozusagen. Die Belgier haben das kolonialisiert.
Ein Großteil des Gebietes war lange Zeit im Privateigentum des belgischen Königs, also Ende des 19.
Jahrhunderts, der dort auf brutalste Weise geherrscht hat und das wirklich als
sein Privateigentum und auch die Menschen als sein Privateigentum behandelt
hat, auch dort Rohstoffe ausgebeutet hat. Kautschuk war damals ein ganz wichtiger
Rohstoff, der dort ausgebeutet wurde.
Und dann kamen eben die mineralischen Rohstoffe dazu und teilweise sehen wir,
dass es sogar noch die gleichen Firmen sind, die heute sozusagen,
dass es in einer Firma noch eine Kontinuität gibt, die schon damals sozusagen
im Dienste dann der belgischen Krone die Rohstoffausbeutung übernommen hat,
die heute noch die Weiterverarbeitung übernimmt.
Und so, das heißt, da gibt es bei den Firmen, glaube ich, eine größere Kontinuität
als sozusagen politisch, wobei man auch sagen muss, Kongo hat gar nicht so viele
unterschiedliche Regierungen gehabt, da gab es gar nicht so viele Wechsel,
aber die Verhältnisse vor Ort sind trotzdem instabil.
Also es gibt ja sozusagen Patrice Lumumba, hat man vielleicht schon mal gehört,
Der sozusagen nach der Dekolonialisierung sozusagen dort eigentlich eine sozialistische
und selbstbestimmte sozusagen Regierung aufbauen wollte,
der von der CIA sozusagen unterstützt, von der CIA ermordet wurde,
weil die Amerikaner gesagt haben, also es ist jetzt keine Verschwörungstheorie.
Das ist so, so haben ja eben auch die ehemaligen Kolonialmächte und die USA
auch nach dem Formellen Ende des Kolonialismus weiter geschaltet und gewaltet
auf dem afrikanischen Kontinent, wie sie wollten,
mal den einen Herrscher unterstützt und mal den anderen gestürzt und so ist
es zum Beispiel dort gewesen.
Es ist ja zum Beispiel Kongo.
Bei der Goldproduktion könnte man das ähnlich sehen wie bei anderen bei der Goldproduktion.
Also es gibt ja noch andere Stoffe, die sozusagen eine Rolle spielen.
Lithium. Der Punkt ist, glaube ich, zu zeigen…
Dass die weltweit ergehenden Konzerne sehr strategische Interessen haben,
wie sie seit Jahrzehnten vertreten, da ist wenig zu sagen Instabilität.
Und das heißt auch nicht unbedingt, also die Diagnose ist erstmal richtig,
aber das heißt nicht unbedingt, dass jeder einzelne von den Staaten,
die hier betroffen ist von dieser Art von Rohstoffausbeutung oder auch andersrum
vom Elektromüll abladen und so, da könnte auch die andere Seite sozusagen.
Da kommen wir gleich noch dazu.
Genau. Die sind nicht alle instabil in diesem Sinne. Also da sind schon auch
einige gestandene Demokratien dabei, die auch teilweise sehr prosperierend sind.
Dennoch haben sich solche Strukturen erhalten, die natürlich auch schwer abzuwehren sind.
Also das ist jetzt nicht, wir wollen nicht so ein Bild zeichnen sozusagen von
dem afrikanischen Kontinent oder auch teilweise eben Südafrika und Asien.
Das sind alle so eine schlimme Diktatur und so ist es nicht mehr.
Aber dennoch haben sich so eine sehr langfristigen…
Auch ein Beispiel für dieses sozusagen, es ist eben nicht so,
dass es alles ganz wild ist, aber trotzdem ist die Truppe noch so?
Na, da würde man vor allen Dingen Südafrika nennen oder so. Oder könnte man
aber auch, Chile wäre auch ein gutes Beispiel eigentlich.
Also Chile, Peru, Bolivien nehme ich mal aus, aber Argentinien sind ja schon
lange demokratisch, haben auch eigene Industrien und haben jetzt trotzdem zu
kämpfen mit dem zum Teil unregulierten Lithiumabbau.
Genau, Lithium ist ein anderer Rohstoff, der eben auch für die Akkus total wichtig
ist, der auch total begehrt ist und dort eben sehr stark geworden ist.
Aber wie kommt das da in Ländern wie Chile und Argentinien, dass es eigentlich
eine stabile Demokratie gibt und dann aber trotzdem der Rohstoffabbau in der
Hand von Firmen ist, die dann auch wann das herkommen?
Also zum Teil liegt es daran, dass es einfach Länder sind, die keine staatlichen
Unternehmen haben, die das fördern, die also sehr stark neoliberal geprägt sind
in ihrer Wirtschaft. Das gilt sicherlich für Chile.
Das gilt so schon klar ist, dass es Unternehmen sein werden,
die profitieren werden vom Lithiumabbau.
Und dann auch Kontexte, in denen eben europäische Unternehmen beispielsweise
aus der Schweiz oder aus Kanada,
aus dem globalen Norden sehr stark da reingehen und dann mit Regierungen Verträge abschließen.
Und das liegt daran, dass die eben nicht in erster Linie protektionistisch orientiert sind,
sondern durchaus sich auch ein Wirtschaftswachstum davon versprechen,
dass diese Unternehmen des globalen Ordens die Förderung vornehmen und die Widerstände
aus der Zivilgesellschaft,
aus den betroffenen Regionen auch einfach überhaupt keinen Anklang finden bei
ihren jeweiligen Regierungen.
Also im Prinzip die Hoffnung, dass vielleicht nicht genügend Anspruch,
dass der Reichtum tatsächlich dem Land zugutekommen könnte.
Das krasseste Beispiel gerade ist ja Javier Mele in Argentinien,
der sagt, Elon Musk, komm du bitte her und baue hier das Lithium ab. Wir wollen das.
Und apropos Widerstand aus der Zivilgesellschaft, sozusagen die Zivilgesellschaft
selbst ist nicht stark genug oder nicht zahlreich genug oder hat kein Interesse daran, das zu ändern?
Wir haben jetzt vorbeikommen, das ist massiv.
Wir werden bestimmt noch Beispiele haben, das gibt es schon.
Widerstand gibt es ganz stark, aber der findet eben nicht den politischen Anklang.
Also im Prinzip sind das häufig indigene Gruppen, die vor Ort sich sehr, sehr stark wehren,
die aber entweder von den Unternehmen direkt oder eben auch von Sicherheitsdiensten
oder auch von den Regierungen im Prinzip unterdrückt werden.
Also und viele Proteste finden auch dort einfach keinen Anklang.
Also man hat eine ganz starke Asymmetrie zwischen Bürgerinnen und Bürgern und
den Regierungen vor Ort.
Genau, hängt natürlich auch immer von der Region ab sozusagen.
Demokratische Republik Kongo ist eines der ärmsten Länder der Welt,
hohe Armutsquote, Hungerquote und so weiter.
Da ist Zivilgesellschaft dann eh nochmal anders strukturiert.
Also das ist aber schon zu sagen aus der Kategorie, wenn die Leute nur genug
hungern, haben sie nicht die Zeit, Revolution zu machen. Also,
naja, also ich frage mich gerade schon, du wohnst in einem Land,
was sozusagen einen Rohstoff hat,
der potenziell irgendwie sehr, sehr, sehr viel wert ist und du hast auch maybe einzelne Gruppen,
die sich dagegen wehren, also es gibt sozusagen schon politische Anknüpfungspunkte,
aber es findet sich keine breite Mehrheit in der Gesellschaft,
die so viel Druck erzeugen kann, dass das Konsequenzen hat.
Also es hängt eben von Region zu Region ganz unterschiedlich ab,
würde ich sagen. Also so pauschal gesprochen würde ich, kann man es vielleicht
für die Demokratische Republik Kongo so sagen.
Aber eben auch, weil es natürlich sozusagen, dass es jetzt nicht die Kobaltabbau-Region,
aber gewalttätige Gruppen gibt, gibt es ja gerade viel Berichterstattung,
dass es sozusagen im Osten des Landes große Kämpfe gibt.
Ja, da gibt es einfach sozusagen nicht die Möglichkeit überhaupt.
Es ist auch ein komplexes Gefühl.
Aber es gibt natürlich auch NGO, das will ich nochmal eben sagen,
es gibt natürlich auch zivilgesellschaftliche Organisationen vor Ort,
die Aufklärungsarbeit machen, die auch internationale Aufklärungsarbeit machen,
die zusammen mit Amnesty International zum Beispiel, ja sozusagen das anprangern,
aber es ist natürlich ein Kampf David gegen Goliath.
Was es auch komplizierter macht ist, das betrifft jetzt wiederum Lateinamerika
und den Lithiumabbau, dass diese Bevölkerungen ja zum Teil auch hoffen, vertreten.
Von dem Reichtum zu profitieren oder eben Kompensationen bekommen beispielsweise.
Und dort kann es dann dazu führen, dass so eine Community dann auch einfach
zerstritten ist und ein Teil für den Abbau ist und ein Teil dagegen ist und
dass die Mobilisierung schwächt.
Aber prinzipiell sind das schon Konstellationen, in denen man ein krasses Ungleichgewicht
findet mit Blick auf den Einfluss, den so eine protestierende Zivilgesellschaft nehmen kann.
Es gibt glaube ich noch einen Aspekt, den wir dazunehmen sollen.
Also es fehlt auch oft die Möglichkeit, wie wir sie hier kennen,
rechtsstaatliche Wege zu gehen, also sich zum Beispiel durchzuklagen.
Also es fehlen vielfach Umweltbesetze, menschenrechtliche Möglichkeiten sich
durchzusetzen. Also es ist ja auch die Frage, wie organisiert sich diese Zivilgesellschaft?
Ist natürlich auch nicht gleich, wir reden jetzt quasi ja über die Welt und
das ist ja unterschiedlich, aber ein Muster ist schon, dass die Möglichkeit
sich auch mit Hilfe von zum Beispiel großen Organisationen wie eben Endesty
auch rechtlich durchzusetzen fehlt in der Regel.
Genau, es gab vor ein paar Jahren sehr interessanten Versuch,
das gerichtlich durchzusetzen.
Da haben nämlich Opfer eines Grubenunglücks Kobaltabbau im Kongo und Angehörige
von denen versucht, in den USA sozusagen Verantwortliche vor Gericht zu bringen,
indem sie nämlich gesagt haben, hier Apple,
Dell und andere, in euren Geräten sind diese Rohstoffe verbaut.
Ihr wisst, wie die Arbeitsbedingungen vor Ort sind.
Auch Google war mit angeklagt und so weiter. Ihr wisst, wie die Arbeitsbedingungen vor Ort sind.
Ihr müsst eine Verantwortung dafür tragen, dass es diese Unfälle gab,
beispielsweise, die sind abgeschmettert worden.
Ich habe jetzt noch so ein paar Gedankenstränge im Kopf. Das eine ist,
nur ob ich es richtig verstanden habe.
Wenn ich euch so höre, schwingt sozusagen mit, die eigentliche Lösung dieses
Problems wäre, wenn in so rohstoffreichen Ländern der Rohstoffabbau...
In einer möglichst demokratisch oder vielleicht auch sozialistisch organisierten
Regierung von staatseigenen Betrieben abgebaut wurde, damit sozusagen der Reichtum im Land verbleibt.
Ist das sozusagen die Ideallösung?
Das ist nur einer von vielen Wegen. Eine andere Antwort wäre auch,
den Abbau anders oder gar nicht zu gestalten.
Man muss schon sagen, dass hier auch Ressourcen gehoben werden und hierbei Umwelt
unwiederbringlich zerstört wird.
Die menschenunwürdigen Bedingungen wären auch nicht gerechtfertigt,
wenn das dem staatlichen Reichtum zugute käme.
Ich war jetzt davon ausgegangen, wenn man das so organisiert,
dann achtet man natürlich auch darauf, dass die Leute das abbauen.
Aber das ist ja eine Preisfrage am Ende. Du musstest ja immer noch zu einem
gewissen Preis produzieren. Insofern wäre die Antwort immer noch die gleiche.
Möglicherweise nicht möglich unter menschenwürdigen Bedingungen.
Für ökonomische Gerechtigkeit und Teilhabe wäre sicherlich, also Abbau ist das
eine, das andere ist die Weiterverarbeitung.
Also das, was die Lithiumstarkenländer zum Beispiel ganz deutlich machen,
aber auch im Kongo immer wieder der Wunsch ist,
Batteriefabriken vor Ort bauen, nicht sozusagen die Rohstoffe erst nach China
bringen, dort weiterverarbeiten lassen und dort dann die Batterien herstellen,
sondern vor Ort auch am besten Batterieproduktion machen.
Aber es stimmt natürlich sozusagen, am besten müssen, bauen wir insgesamt,
brauchen wir weniger Rohstoffe, weil die sind ja Ausdruck, sozusagen dieser
krasse Rohstoffabbau ist ja Ausdruck eines Überkonsums, den wir auch im Digitalen haben.
Die Anzahl der Geräte, die weltweit Menschen haben, vor allen Dingen im globalen
Norden, steigt enorm. Der Elektroschrott steigt.
Aber ich frage mich sozusagen, ob das vor Ort auch verargumentierbar wäre.
Und ob das den Rahmen dieser Sendung sprengt. Weil dann kommt man wieder sozusagen
zu einem ganz anderen Problem.
Im Prinzip schon, vor dem Hintergrund, dass wenn insgesamt weniger gefördert
wird, aber unter anderen Bedingungen, man ja einkalkulieren muss,
dass möglicherweise dann die Weltpreise auch steigen und das heißt,
man könnte sein Metall auch für teurer verkaufen.
Und die Kosten für die Regionen sind enorm. Wir haben jetzt gerade über Menschenrechte
gesprochen, aber beispielsweise Energieverbrauch und Wasserverbrauch sind auch
ein riesengroßes Problem.
Und da haben wir noch gar nicht über Biodiversität gesprochen.
Umweltverschmutzung auch, genau.
Genau, also Schwermetalle, die in den Umkreis geraten, aber insbesondere auch
der Wasserverbrauch, Erosion, die durch den Abbau geschehen.
Das heißt, das sind alles Kosten, die in diesen Regionen nur anfallen und die
billige Preise eben noch weniger erträglich machen.
Und es gibt keine Anreize für
das Recycling. Die Recyclingquote sind immer noch unglaublich schlecht.
Also es wird fast alles, also weit über 90 Prozent wird sozusagen weggeworfen
und es gibt sozusagen wenig, wo man auf wenig Anreize ökonomisch erhört, dass man mehr recycelt.
Das ist natürlich auch eine langjährige Forderung schon.
Ein anderes Ding ist, es gibt ja, jetzt weiß ich gar nicht, ob in der EU oder
in Deutschland, es gibt ein Lieferkettengesetz. Es gibt zumindest hier sozusagen
erste Versuche, was zu machen.
Gibt es international auch Bestrebungen, das eben auch für diese Basisrohstoffe
für die Digitalisierung mal hinzukriegen?
Also es gibt bestimmt Leute, die die Idee haben, aber wird irgendwo dran gearbeitet?
Also die EU hat ja auch ein Lieferkettengesetz und da würden diese Rohstoffe
auch einfach, da fallen die drunter, so diese Rohstoffe.
Wir sehen aber leider politisch ja gerade das Gegenteil. Also in den USA,
die sind absolut weit davon entfernt, jemals sowas sozusagen zu erlassen unter
Trump erst recht, aber auch schon unter Biden nicht.
Und wir sehen ja auch in Europa und in Deutschland sozusagen,
dass das eigentlich rückabgewickelt werden soll.
Also die konservativen, Liberalen, selbst die Grünen, Robert Habeck sagt ja
schon, ach nee, Lieferkettengesetz, wir wollen euch einem Unternehmen nicht so viel Arbeit machen.
Ja, da würde ich jetzt erstmal… Schöne Idee,
Aber sozusagen, du würdest es auch nicht retten?
Nein, ich würde schon noch einen Lichtblick entgegensetzen. Also es gibt heute
deutlich mehr, so seit zwei oder drei Jahren auch auf europäischer Ebene,
es gibt mehr Transparenzpflichten und so.
Du kannst heute auch wissenschaftlich besser darüber forschen,
weil mehr Informationen vorliegen zu diesem ganzen Rohstoffabbau und auch von
den Konzernen selber. Also da ist ein bisschen was passiert.
Da gibt es quasi auch eine europäische Richtlinie für diese stärkere Transparenz.
Das betrifft nicht nur Konzerne aus Europa, sondern auch diejenigen Konzerne,
die in Europa an den Börsen gelistet sind.
Also immerhin das hat dazu geführt, zumindest aus meiner Sicht,
dass seit zwei, drei Jahren deutlich mehr Daten verfügbar sind und Infos darüber.
Also man muss ja über das Problem auch sprechen können mit Fakten,
sonst kann man das immer so leicht wegschieben.
Aber das ist dann sozusagen eher der Schritt zu einer potenziellen Lösung.
Ja, natürlich. Für mich ist das ein Lichtblick, weil das immer der erste sein
muss, sonst kannst du ja nicht wirklich drüber reden.
Vor allen Dingen nicht, was die Konzerne betrifft, denn die sind natürlich sehr
unterschiedlich, also von sich aus sehr unterschiedlich transparent.
Die großen Tech-Brother-Konzerne, ups, wie heißen die richtig?
Ja, Big Tech-Brother. Die haben natürlich oft aus Imagegründen schon eine relativ
hohe Transparenz. Also da kann man ein bisschen gucken, so nach den Rohstoffen
und auch nach den Ländern, wo die was herholen.
Aber die Konzerne, die die abbauen, haben sie zum Beispiel längst nicht so stärker
Maß. Also wahrscheinlich, weil die auf ihr Image auch nicht so stark achten müssen.
Also das wäre ja immer so der erste Schritt, dass man sich wenigstens mal ansieht,
was ist denn jetzt der Ist-Zustand?
Es klang jetzt schon ein paar Mal an, ich würde sagen direkt ans andere Ende
der Hardware springen, nämlich das Recycling.
Das hat man vielleicht auch schon mal gehört. Der Elektroschot wird aus Europa
irgendwo hin verklappt und da gibt es riesige Müllhalden. und da kriechen arme Menschen und Kinder.
Genau, aber ist das sozusagen, wie real ist das? Wo passiert das? Wie viel passiert das?
Das ist real. Also vielleicht, ich habe mal ein paar Zahlen mitgebracht von der UN.
Ihr haltet euch alle fest, das ist schlimm.
Also erst mal sozusagen die Zahl der digitalen Geräte weltweit.
Wie ist das so verteilt in Weltregionen? Wer hat wie viele Geräte?
Also der weltweite Schnitt sind 3,6 Geräte pro Person.
In der Nordafrika, also Mena-Region, Middle East, North Africa sind es 1,5 Geräte pro Person.
Asia-Pacific 3,1, Lateinamerika auch, Zentral- und Osteuropa 4.
Westeuropa 9,4 Geräte pro Person und Nordamerika halt 13,4 Geräte.
Was ist ein Gerät?
Ein Handy, ein Computer, ein Tablet sozusagen.
Fernseher mittlerweile auch.
Und die Zahlen haben sich fast verdoppelt im globalen Norden in den letzten zehn Jahren.
Das ist ja was, was wir alle erleben, oder?
Also wir sitzen hier bei mir sozusagen in meinem Studio und ich gucke sozusagen
rum, komme ich auf die neuen Geräte? Ja, ich komme auf die neuen Geräte definitiv.
Das ist natürlich sozusagen harsch sozusagen.
Dann auch zu realisieren, selbst sitzt man jetzt hier vor dem Mikrofon,
was auch Teil des Problems ist letztlich.
Das ist so.
Ja und da passiert jetzt hier gerade mal noch was parallel. Also ich meine,
wir haben auch noch den riesen KI-Investitionshype.
Also das bedeutet, dass die großen Tech-Konzerne, die kaufen sich literally
Millionen Hardware-Schrott, der, wenn dieser Hype vorbei ist,
nicht mehr benötigt wird, weil er sozusagen aufgabenspezifisch ist. So richtig Millionen.
Okay, ich würde sagen, weil wir heute nicht so mega viel Zeit haben,
würde ich sagen, trotzdem wieder zurückkommen.
Nämlich, wir wissen also, wir haben viel davon, Elektroschrott. Was passiert damit?
Genau, Elektroschrott 10,5 Millionen Tonnen im Jahr 2022 laut UN.
Global natürlich auch krass ungleich verteilt. Ja, die ärmsten Länder,
so ist die Kategorie bei der UN, 0,21 Kilogramm pro Person Elektroschrott im Jahr.
Industrieländer 3,25 Kilogramm Elektroschrott pro Jahr. Also mehr als das 30-fache.
Und Zahlen von der WHO in 2021. 13 Millionen Frauen und 18 Millionen Kinder
arbeiten auf Elektroschrottmüllheiden im globalen Süden.
Millionen.
Jesus. Nochmal kurz, Elektroschrott ist schon eine wertvolle Ressource auch.
Was heißt Arbeiten?
Genau. Also Elektroschrott kann eine wertvolle Ressource
sein, weil da natürlich diese Rohstoffe drin sind, die ja eigentlich überwiegend auch recycelbar wären.
Das heißt, es gibt dort einfach wirklich riesige Müllhalden,
beispielsweise in Accra, Ghana.
Wo ist die riesigste der Welt? Die kann man vom Weltraum sehen.
Und wo ist die? Ghana in Accra. Riesengroß, wo nicht nur Elektroschrott landet,
aber auch Elektroschrott.
Und dort arbeiten, ja, also es ist eigentlich zynisch, das eben so zu nennen,
aber dort leben Menschen und verbrennen eben Elektroschrott.
Und um dort sozusagen aus den Überresten diese Rohstoffe zu gewinnen,
beispielsweise Gold oder Kupfer wiederverwertbar zu machen. und dann weiterverkaufen zu können.
Und jetzt auch zahlen der WHO, wenn Arbeiter in Gold und alte Geräte recyceln,
verbrennen, um eben Gold und Kupfer zu gewinnen, dann atmen sie bis zu 1000
giftige Substanzen ein. Die machen das natürlich ungeschützt.
Das wollte ich gerade fragen. Also Verbrennen ist ja nicht sozusagen wie Holz
ins Feuerwerfen, sondern halt Leiterplatten, Chips und so weiter.
Da gasen Dinge aus, die man nicht einatmen sollte.
Tödlich.
Tödlich. Jesus. Und ist das hier dann sozusagen dasselbe wie beim Rohstoffabbau,
nämlich es gibt genug ökonomischen Druck vor Land und keine Interessen,
sodass Leute das auch absehbar machen werden, weil davon profitiert wird?
Es ist ein informaler Sektor. Das ist nicht reguliert. Das machen die Menschen
zum Überleben. Im Prinzip ist das wie Müll sammeln, das ist Müll weiterverarbeitet.
Aber wie sind dann die Schleife dann zurück? Also die verbrennen das und holen das raus?
Und es wird dann verkauft?
An Zwischenhändler sozusagen, Rohstoffhändler. Und an irgendeiner Stelle wird
das auch wieder eingespeist sozusagen über die gleichen Unternehmen sozusagen,
die es dann wieder in den Rohstoffkreislauf einspeisen.
Es wird berichtet auch schon seit vielen Jahren.
Die BBC hat sich zum Beispiel mit ganzen Reihen stark gemacht.
Gerade die BBC, die ja vom afrikanischen Kontinent traditionell viel berichtet.
Das ist überhaupt kein Geheimnis oder so. Jeder kann das wissen.
Und auch die Versuche, was man dagegen machen könnte, das ist jetzt nicht ein neues Problem.
Es wird nur in einem krass hohen Maße schlimmer, weil wir im Sinne von globalem
Norden noch viel mehr mit der Digitalisierung von allem produzieren.
Das steigt sozusagen exponentiell.
Jetzt kann man, also das ist ja erstmal sozusagen ein systemisches Problem,
die kann man immer schlecht individuell lösen, aber vielleicht ist das doch
sozusagen einer der Punkte, wo man sagen, vielleicht kann ich ja mal ein kleines
Schärfchen dabei, Schärflein beitragen.
Das eine ist natürlich am Anfang dieser Kette weniger kaufen und dann,
wenn man es kann sozusagen, gibt
es ja auch Firmen, die versuchen da transparent zu sein oder sogar fair.
Am anderen Ende der Kette ist, kann man, gibt es eine Möglichkeit zu versuchen,
sein Gerät so loszuwerden, dass es nicht da landet?
Also weil, ich will zum Beispiel denken, wenn ich jetzt hier in Deutschland,
gibt es ja keine Ahnung, kann ich hier in Berlin zur BSR gehen und dann kann
ich halt Elektroschrott abgeben.
Ist das dann safe oder ist das dann nur eine Zwischenstufe und das landet dann doch dort?
Also anderes Beispiel, wenn ich hier so, in Berlin gibt es diese Autodinger,
wenn du die verkaufst, also da hast du so einen Zettel im Auto und dann kannst
du deine Schrottkarre, egal wie schlimm sie ist, kriegst du dir noch für ein
paar Hunderter los. Wenn du das machst, weißt du im Prinzip,
dass es exakt diesen Weg auch geht.
Das heißt, da hat man die Wahl. Ich kann es auch ordnungsgemäß verschrotten.
Wie ist das bei Elektroschrott?
Ich will jetzt nicht für einzelne Unternehmen meine Hand ins Feuer legen,
kann ich dir jetzt nicht sagen.
Ich würde jetzt erstmal davon ausgehen, dass es auch Möglichkeiten gibt sozusagen
oder vertrauenswürdige Akteure gibt, die das sozusagen Recycling hier betreiben,
weil es eben auch ein Interesse daran gibt, eigentlich sozusagen die Rohstoffe
auch hier, sage ich jetzt mal, zu behalten.
Also die EU versucht gerade zum Beispiel das Recycling innerhalb Europas auch voranzubringen.
Aber ja, lieber selber bitte überprüfen, was genau passiert,
wenn man sein Handy bei Ikea oder an anderen Sammelstellen sozusagen,
wo es solche Dinge gibt, in den Schlitz wirft.
Was an kolonialen Strukturen perfide ist ja, ist, dass sie wirklich sehr stark
Unternehmen betreffen und auch die Verantwortung von Regierungen versuchen zu betonen.
Im Prinzip haben wir 40 Jahre postkoloniale Theorie oder 50,
60 Jahre, je nachdem wie weit man zurückblickt. Und die Fragen,
die du zurechtstellst, was können wir als Endnutzerinnen oder als Bürgerinnen
eigentlich tun, die sind unheimlich wichtig.
Aber ich sag mal, die besondere Stärke der postkolonialen Theorie ist eben auch
diese ganzen Verknüpfungen aufzuzeigen.
Und sehr häufig ist die erste Antwort eben nicht das, was Endnutzerinnen und
Endnutzer tun können, abgesehen davon, dass wir uns im Konsum beschränken und
dass wir aufpassen, was wir mit unserem Müll machen,
sondern auch wirklich die Verantwortung zu sehen, insbesondere von Unternehmen
und auch von Regierungen und zu schauen, was sind das für Märkte,
wie reguliert sind die eigentlich.
Was steht in den Handelsabkommen drin und tatsächlich ist es entsprechend auch
sicherlich eine unserer Aufgaben in der Gegenwart und in der Zukunft noch besser
zu verstehen, Wie die Müllindustrie funktioniert beispielsweise.
Ich bin da keine Expertin für, aber zunehmend merke ich, wie wichtig das ist.
Oder auch eben, wie das Vergabewesen funktioniert, sowohl hier als auch in anderen Ländern.
Denn das sind im Prinzip die Hebel, die man hat mit Blick auf Unternehmen.
Also man könnte sagen, europäische Unternehmen,
schweizerische Unternehmen, wenn wir wissen, dass ihr euch wie die Schweine
verhaltet woanders auf der Welt, dann bekommt ihr innerhalb der Europäischen
Union keine Aufträge mehr.
All sowas ist im Prinzip möglich und zeigt uns eben auch auf,
wo noch weitere Stellschrauben sind jenseits dessen, was wir als Einzelne tun können.
Ich habe den Eindruck, ich finde das natürlich richtig, das muss man immer dazu
betonen, man sollte diese Probleme nicht individualisieren.
Aber trotzdem ist es ja letztlich eine Stärke von Europa und vielleicht auch
gerade von Deutschland, dass die Leute super viel Interesse daran haben.
Die wollen sich auch persönlich richtig verhalten, das erlebe ich jedenfalls
sehr oft. Ich habe in letzter Zeit ziemlich viel gemacht zu Umweltschutz und
KI und was mir entgegenschlägt, ist super viel Interesse.
Das heißt, die Frage, die du stellst, was kann ich eigentlich machen mit meinem
alten Handy, was ich wirklich nicht mehr verwenden will, die ist mir jetzt ganz
oft begegnet. Leute wollen das wissen und ich glaube da kommt natürlich auch
wieder gewisser politischer Druck zustande.
Wenn nämlich eine große Mehrheit in der Bevölkerung sagt, ey,
das will ich so nicht, da möchte ich was ändern, macht das natürlich auch wieder politischen Druck.
Insofern sind diese individualisierten Fragen auch eine Möglichkeit für den
Druck aufzubauen, wenn das nämlich genug Leute stellen.
Und das haben wir in anderen, also bei Umweltbewegung gibt es ja viele Beispiele,
man sollte das glaube ich auch nicht geringschätzen, denn das Interesse ist auf jeden Fall da.
Also politischen Druck braucht es aber auf jeden Fall, weil ich meine,
wir wollen ja über andere Themen sprechen heute, deshalb will ich es jetzt vielleicht
gar nicht so lange ausführen, aber um es sozusagen an der Stelle nochmal klar
zu machen, im Buch setzen wir uns da auch sehr mit der ambivalenten Rolle der EU dann auseinander,
also vielleicht einmal der Vollständigkeit halber, das Buch habe ich zusammen
mit Sven Hilbig von Brot für die Welt geschrieben und dessen Motivation war
ganz stark zu sagen, okay,
Also der seit langem zu diesen Themen arbeitet, auch mit Partnerorganisationen
aus dem globalen Süden und der sagt, okay, der deutlich gemacht hat, okay,
die EuropäerInnen und die EU, die sozusagen denken immer, dass sie alles richtig
machen und dass sie ja schon, wer weiß, wie vorbildlich wären und die EU betont
in ihrer Digitalpolitik immer die Werteorientierung, ja,
dritter Weg der Digitalisierung zwischen dem Tech-Autoritarismus Chinas und
dem entfesselten Tech-Kapitalismus der USA und so weiter.
Und ganz klar, wenn wir uns jetzt den Rohstoffbereich angucken,
die EU hat gerade mit dem Critical Raw Materials Act definiert,
folgende sind kritische Rohstoffe, strategische Rohstoffe, da stehen die,
über die wir gesprochen haben, auf jeden Fall mit rein, weil sie so wichtig
sind für unterschiedliche Bereiche.
Und da werden jetzt strategische Partnerschaften angestrebt,
zum Beispiel mit der Demokratischen Republik Kongo.
So, und dann gibt es halt so ein paar Transparenzpflichten und dann gibt es
halt so ein paar sozusagen irgendwie Zertifizierungsmechanismen,
die dann so ein bisschen so ein Feigenblatt sein sollen, aber allen ist klar,
dass sich, wenn sich nicht grundsätzlich was ändert an diesen Dynamiken,
dass das sozusagen diese Dynamiken eigentlich fortschreibt, diese Ausbeutungsdynamiken vorschreibt.
Ja, Olaf Scholz, stellvertretend der deutsche Bundeskanzler,
hat vor zweit noch, hatte im Interview mit der SZ gesagt, wir können uns es
nicht mehr erlauben, in Rohstofffragen etepidete zu sein.
Was für eine dreiste Aussage.
Also gut, ich dachte eigentlich, das letzte Chaos gerade wäre das zur Wahl gewesen.
Vielleicht schaffen wir das noch hier vor der Wahl rauszubringen.
Könnt ihr auch nochmal gucken sozusagen.
Das ist ja eigentlich nur, was der Ingo sagt, dass wir sind Teil des Problems
in Deutschland, aber auch in Europa.
Und so ein bisschen sich hinstellen, als wenn wir sind irgendwie besser als
die Amis, was wir vielleicht sogar sind, hilft ja noch nicht,
wenn wir auch Teil des Problems sind.
Aber vielleicht ist es besser als die Amis einfach nicht gut genug.
Ja, richtig.
Das ist ganz wichtig, denn das ist tatsächlich häufig ja auch die Perspektive aus dem globalen Süden.
Also wenn sie mal woanders sind und über Europa sprechen, dann wird Europa auch
als Vampir wahrgenommen.
Absolut keine Glaubwürdigkeit mehr.
Nein, also einfach eine moralische Überheblichkeit, die nicht gerechtfertigt
ist und da gibt es so eine lange Latte an Beispielen von Unternehmen,
die sich dort wirklich fürchterlich verhalten haben und deswegen wird eben viel
von dem, was wir hier hören, dort als Lehrerdiskurs empfunden.
Wir hatten ja jetzt quasi gerade Hardware-Kolonialismus, wenn man es so sagen
kann. Es gibt aber auch Software-Kolonialismus, wenn man das so sagen kann.
Und da gibt es also wieder das, was man vielleicht schon mal gehört hat,
das Bild des Clickworkers, der so ein bisschen das Problem umschreibt,
dass es dann so in verschiedenen Ausprägungen gibt.
Ingo, du hattest jetzt gerade sozusagen, für das Rohstoff konnte man sozusagen
sehr gut am Beispiel Kobold und Kongo erstmal erzählen.
Gibt es für diese Art von Kolonialismus, von digitalem Kolonialismus auch ein Beispiel?
Ja, relativ bekannt ist aus den letzten Jahren das Thema Content-Moderation.
Also die outgesourceten Arbeitskräfte, die die sozialen Medien sicher und sauber halten,
deren Arbeitsbedingungen, die fehlende psychologische Betreuung,
Unterstützung, die schlechten Arbeitsbedingungen, die kurzen Verträge,
die schlechten Löhne und so weiter.
Und genau das Gleiche gibt es eigentlich für das, was man so KI nennt.
Vielleicht muss man das einmal ein bisschen genauer beschreiben.
Also wir sitzen hier sozusagen im globalen Norden und sind da auf unseren tollen
sozialen Netzwerken unterwegs.
Und dann treibt jemand Unsinn. Und dann wird das Content moderiert und dann
gibt es so riesige, das sind so
Büroverschläge oder wie man das bezeichnen soll?
Die gibt es inzwischen auch im globalen Norden. Also da hat sich inzwischen
eine Industrie gebildet, die sozusagen, also auch sozusagen dann Hubs gibt.
Deutschland ist für den europäischen, für verschiedene europäischen Märkte auch
ein großer Hub, wo dann, da weist Adio Dini, Karin Forscher,
mit dem wir für das Buch viel gesprochen haben, auch vom, der auch beim WZB war,
zum Beispiel darauf hin, dass es aber natürlich auch hier relativ stark die
an den randgedrängten, marginalisierten sind, oft sozusagen fragwürdiger Aufenthaltsstatus
oder der an der Arbeit hängt und so. Das ist mal das eine.
Und das andere ist aber, dass trotzdem sozusagen für Outsourcing in der Tech-Industrie
die großen Zentren sich im globalen Süden befinden, für Outsourcing aller Art.
Also Kenia ist, glaube ich, auch medial am bekanntesten wohl.
Kenia war jetzt viel, aber auch Indien historisch gesehen ja ganz stark,
Philippinen, aber auch in Lateinamerika, Brasilien, Kolumbien so ein bisschen.
Und ein konkretes Beispiel ist ChatGPT, das sozusagen ein bisschen aktueller ist.
Kleiner Schritt zurück sozusagen, wie funktioniert ChatGPT? Was ist das?
Also wenn wir heute über das, was wir heute so generative KI gemeinhin nennen,
basiert ja auf großen Modellen, Sprachmodellen, Bildmodellen und ähnlichem,
Also riesige Datenmengen, mit denen sie gefüttert werden. Und das sind ja eben
keine unstrukturierten Daten.
Die können sich nicht einfach alle Daten da reinfüttern, sondern Daten müssen
aufbereitet werden, müssen annotiert sein, müssen die richtigen Metadaten haben.
So, das ist eine Arbeit, die händisch gemacht wird, überwiegend.
Und das heißt, da braucht es sehr viele Arbeitskräfte, die Datensätze,
sei es Bilder, aber eben auch Textdatensätze, labeln.
So, und ChatGPT ist ein tolles Beispiel, kennen wir alle, Riesendurchbruch,
hat den großen Hype um generative KI ausgelöst in den letzten Jahren, begeistert viele...
Ich sage jetzt mal in Anführungszeichen, weil es eben so gut antworten kann,
weil es immer die richtigen Dinge sagt oder oft richtige Dinge sagt,
aber dazu gehört auch, dass es die richtigen Dinge nicht sagt.
Chat-GPT beleidigt dich nicht, Chat-GPT gibt dir keine Kinderpornografischen
Inhalte, keine Gewaltdarstellung und ähnliches. Und das tut es,
weil ArbeiterInnen Datensätze aufbereitet haben, die genau solche Inhalte enthalten haben.
Also die Inhalte, die ChatGPT meiden soll, die es nicht beantworten darf.
Das heißt, es gab in Kenia, in Nairobi, ArbeiterInnen, die haben Tag ein,
Tag aus, hunderte Seiten, Kindesmissbrauchsdarstellung,
Sodomie, alles mögliche, all die furchtbaren Dinge, die man sich vorstellen
kann, Gewaltdarstellung, Hinrichtung und so weiter, Texte davon durchgelesen,
diese Daten aufbereitet, annotiert, um damit ChatGPT zu treffen.
Und die haben eigentlich unter den gleichen Arbeitsbedingungen gearbeitet,
wie das, was wir aus der Content-Moderation können.
Also angestellt bei Outsourcing-Firmen, kurze Verträge, maximal drei Monate,
krasse Überwachung am Arbeitsplatz, keine ausreichende psychologische Unterstützung,
obwohl das anders versprochen wurde.
Die haben teilweise nicht mal Essenspausen, also das ist auch überlangen.
Keine soziale Absicherung, zum Teil auch keinen Schutz vor Übergriffen durch
Kollegen. Alles, was bei uns ganz normal als Arbeitsschutz gewährleistet wird.
Aber die äußern sich natürlich auch. Also wir haben hier im Westen natürlich
die Möglichkeit, diese Stimmen zu hören.
Die fangen an, sich gewerkerflich zu organisieren, aber die stoßen natürlich
an ähnliche Probleme, wie wir es jetzt hatten bei den Rohstoffen.
Sie haben wenig Unterstützung regierungsseitig, sie haben manchmal nicht mehr
Unterstützung von der Opposition, sie haben Schwierigkeiten,
den Rechtsweg zu beschreiten oder können ihn gar nicht beschreiten.
Und sie haben natürlich aber auch in so einer schwierigen Arbeitssituation,
wo sie ja ohnehin schon ausgebeutet sind, auch wenig Möglichkeiten,
Unterstützung zu suchen im Westen.
Also große NGOs oder so, die unterstützen würden.
Ja, was willst du sagen? Also ich weiß, dass es so ist. Ich muss aber trotzdem nochmal fragen.
Bei den Rohstoffketten sozusagen, da ist mir vorstellbar, wie man die so lang
baut, dass das sozusagen, dass das rohe Kobalt dann im iPhone selbst sozusagen
fast schon unsichtbar ist.
Weil da eben auch Verarbeitungsprozesse hinterstehen. Aber die Verbindung hier
ist ja eigentlich viel direkter.
Also es gibt ein Facebook, da wird Content moderiert. Da gab es,
also ich sage jetzt Facebook, weil da gab es eine Doku drüber.
Oder es gibt halt eine JGPT und an dessen Daten, also die Verbindung ist ja
viel direkter, aber trotzdem
funktioniert das. Warum?
Ich finde die gar nicht so viel direkter offen gestanden.
Es gab relativ bald einen Artikel, was war das, Washington Post,
New York Times glaube ich.
In der Times, im Time Magazine.
Relativ bald, nachdem ChatGPT rauskam, für Furore gesorgt hat und weltweit alle
Unternehmen sich Innovation versprechen, durch ChatGPT kam dieser Artikel,
der relativ viel gesagt hat über die unwürdigen Arbeitsbedingungen.
Das heißt, so diskursiv gab es ein Bewusstsein dafür.
Die Frage ist wieder, was kann man denn tatsächlich tun? Wer übt auf wen Druck aus?
Das heißt, es dauert sehr, sehr lange im Prinzip, bis dann vor Ort sich die
Arbeitsbedingungen ändern.
Und insgesamt und hier auch nochmal zurück zum Erbe des kolonialen Zeitalters
im Prinzip doch wieder weltweite Strukturen,
in denen es normalisiert wird, dass in bestimmten Weltregionen Menschen unter
unwürdigen Bedingungen arbeiten und leben, zu früh ihr Leben lassen.
Das ist im Prinzip auch etwas, was die postkoloniale Theorie immer wieder betont.
Es gibt auch ein Mindset weltweit.
Also es gibt nicht nur diese ganz materiellen Märkte und Beziehungen,
Handelsbeziehungen oder Beziehungen zwischen Regierungen und Regierungen,
Unternehmen, Korruption und so weiter, sondern es gibt schon auch so eine Akzeptanz
von unwürdigem Leben auf bestimmten Kontinenten, gefüttert durch Rassismus beispielsweise,
die so ein Stück weit ermöglichen, Dass das, was einen ein Stück weit wirklich
sehr schockieren müsste,
irgendwann abstumpft, normal erscheint.
Wir haben das auch ganz praktisch erlebt. Also ich habe, als ich letztes Jahr
ein Interview hatte mit einem von diesen Menschen, also einfach um mal zu berichten,
wie das da praktisch läuft.
Das war jemand, der sich auch gewerkschaftlich organisiert und dann auch für
eine Veranstaltung hier herfliegen sollte, was dann aber wegen des Visums nicht
klappte. Genau solche Kommentare kriegst du dann heute, also 2024 irgendwie bei Netzpolitik.org.
Sollte die doch froh sein, die kriegen zwei Euro oder zwei Dollar die Stunde.
So richtig so. Also das ist ja nicht irgendwie.
Der Kolonialismus ist halt auch in den Köpfen und auch tatsächlich finde ich,
er findet in letzter Zeit auch wieder Ausdruck.
Leute schämen sich auch nicht mehr dafür, das zu sagen. Also ich finde das ganz
doll erschreckend, weil wir da so teilweise viele Kommentare bekommen haben.
Können die doch froh sein, anderswo kriegen sie nicht zwei Dollar,
da brauchen sie doch bloß Bilder wegklicken.
Also auf eine Weise, aber da wird die übel.
Zumal eher unter dem Interview, wo du genau lesen kannst, was das für Bedingungen sind.
Ich hatte auch letztes Jahr ein Interview mit Milagros Micelli geführt,
die auch am WZB unter anderem Forsch zugezogen hat.
Das WZB ist das Weizmom-Institut.
Genau, das sind zwei verschiedene Institute.
Ach, das ist ein Leibniz-Institut.
Es gibt das WZB und es gibt das Weizmom-Institut und Mila ist am Weizmom-Institut.
Okay, danke. Die auch sozusagen sehr forscht, auch aktivistisch forscht,
so zu diesem Arbeitsbedingungen und dem Outsourcing dahinter,
die auch jetzt gerade ein sehr interessantes Projekt gestartet hat oder das Data Workers Inquiry,
wo sie sozusagen zusammen mit DatenarbeiterInnen aus aller Welt daran arbeiten,
dass die ihre Geschichten erzählen können, ihre Forderungen bringen können.
Also wenn man sich mal einlesen möchte, dann kann man auf netzpolitisch.org
die Interviews lesen, aber man kann auch dorthin gehen und sich wirklich in
unterschiedlichen Medienformen das angucken.
Und ich hatte eben zum Launch dieses Data Workers Inquiry mit ihrem Interview
geführt, in dem sie eben sagte, okay,
was, also auch nochmal darauf hinweist, also was ist denn das für eine Frage,
ob wir jetzt sozusagen, wir sollten nicht mehr danach fragen,
ist 1,50 Euro am Tag, ist das genug oder ist das nicht genug,
sondern wir sollten doch den Blick auf die Unternehmen werfen dahinter.
Aber warum kann ein Unternehmen wie der Meta-Konzern, gerade sind die Jahresberichte
für 2024 rausgekommen, 60 Milliarden Dollar Gewinn hat Meta gemacht.
Warum kann dieses Unternehmen nicht einen Teil dieses Gewinns ausgeben dafür,
Dass… Eigentlich ist die Frage nicht kann, sondern muss. Warum muss eigentlich
nicht ein Unternehmen wie Meta… Genau,
Warum zwingen wir sie nicht als Gesellschaft?
Also mich führt das eigentlich zu der Frage, die jetzt irgendwie in meinem Kopf
sich aufbaut, nämlich, also das Wort Kolonialismus wird benutzt wegen des historischen
Hintergrundes, also weil das auf diesen Strukturen basiert.
Aber wie groß ist der Unterschied zu Kapitalismus eigentlich noch?
Also wenn man es sozusagen von außen, von oben, von draußen anguckt,
kann man eigentlich sagen, also was hier passiert, ist ja schlicht und einfach,
große Konzerne machen das so, dass es am meisten Profit bringt und da,
also sagen, das ist halt günstig sozusagen,
du hast Lena ja gerade erklärt, warum das sozusagen so gut funktioniert,
aber sind die Begriffe austauschbar mittlerweile?
Sind sie nicht. Sie haben eine unterschiedliche Konnotation.
Tatsächlich, und da werde ich jetzt gar nicht einsteigen, gibt es eine relativ
heftige Debatte darüber, ob postkorniale Theorie Sinn macht,
ob sie nicht eher spaltet, was ihr Mehrwert ist.
Und es gibt durchaus Personen, die ähnliche Ausbeutungsstrukturen mit einem
marxistischen, postmarxistischen Vokabular beschreiben und entsprechend eben
von Kapitalismus sprechen oder von Imperialismus sprechen.
Und der besondere Fokus der postkolonialen Theorie ist einer,
der besonders stark ansetzt auf all dem, was eben nicht so materiell ist,
also insbesondere eben den Normen, den Vorstellungen,
auch der Art und Weise, wie Wissen generiert wird, wer entscheidet,
was eigentlich valides Wissen ist.
Das nennt sich dann epistemische Gewalt in der postkolonialen Theorie und einen
besonderen Fokus hat auf Rassismus und wie diese verschiedenen Faktoren,
Rassismus, Sexismus und Kapitalismus, wie die zusammenwirken.
Und man kann im Prinzip also eine ähnliche Kritik auch ohne postkoloniale Theorie
führen, aber die postkoloniale Theorie hat genau diese Historie und den Fokus darauf,
auf Rassismus, auf Sexismus und insbesondere auf diese Nord-Süd-Beziehungen.
Und vielleicht auch eine besonders starke historische Perspektive,
die weiter zurückreicht als die Geschichte des 20. Jahrhunderts.
Okay, da würde ich die Frage anstellen wollen. Gäbe es digitalen Kolonialismus ohne Kapitalismus?
Nach dem, was du sagst, wäre die Antwort ja eigentlich ja. Wie sähe der dann aus?
Naja, wir könnten uns natürlich… Das ist jetzt sehr kontrafaktisch.
Wie würde die Welt aussehen, wenn wir nicht den Kapitalismus hätten?
Genau, aber es geht ja darum, diesen Unterschied zu verstehen.
Oder die Frage, es gibt es… Entschuldigung. Nein, aber die Frage,
die du stellst, ist, gibt es Rassismus ohne Kapitalismus?
Ich würde sagen ja, aber sie sind eng verwoben gewesen, soweit unsere Geschichte zurückreicht.
Entschuldigung, ich würde nicht hinterfragen, ob es Kolonialismus nicht gäbe, sondern den digitalen.
Also nur die Themen, über die wir heute hier sprechen, gäbe es die auch.
Ich finde, man kann es nicht trennen, weil ja auch die Entstehung des Kapitalismus
eng verwoben ist mit dem Kolonialismus.
Also ohne den Kolonialismus, den historischen gäbe, ist Kapitalismus in der
heutigen Form nicht. Diese weltweite Arbeitsteilung, die sozusagen wie globale
Märkte strukturiert sind, das kommt ja aus dem Kolonialismus.
Also dass die Europäer in sozusagen die eroberten Gebiete, die Kolonien einerseits
ausgebeutet haben, was Rohstoffe und Arbeitskraft angeht und andererseits aber
als Absatzmärkte genommen haben,
um ihre Industrieprodukte zu verklappen.
Und sozusagen wiederum teilweise ja auch in Agrarprodukten sehen wir es ja bis heute noch sozusagen,
die Kolonien auch in der Abhängigkeit wirtschaftlich zu bringen von den Metropolen sozusagen.
Das ist ja sozusagen und das strukturiert, wie globale Wirtschaft funktioniert ja bis heute.
Also wenn wir jetzt mal auf Kenia und auf Indien gucken, nehmen wir Kenia als
Beispiel, das ist britische Kolonie gewesen und ist heute eine,
sozusagen hat heute immer noch ein, ich kriege die Platzierung nicht mehr zusammen,
aber auf dem Welthungerindex relativ weit hinten.
Also es ist auch noch eine, obwohl es sozusagen die achtgrößte Ökonomie Afrikas ist,
Sozusagen gibt es dort immer noch extreme Ungleichheit, gibt es dort immer extrem
hohe Arbeitslosigkeit beispielsweise und das ist ja sozusagen etwas,
wo wir einen klaren Link zum Kolonialismus sehen.
Also der Kolonialismus hat Staaten hinterlassen, die allein kaum überlebensfähig
sind, weil die Infrastruktur, wie sie gebaut wurde, nur darauf ausgerichtet wurde,
den Interessen sozusagen der Kolonisatoren zu dienen.
Also Truppen durchs Land bewegen zu können und Rohstoffe aus dem Landesinneren
an die Küste zu bringen, weil die Infrastruktur teilweise sogar von den Kolonialisatoren
noch zerstört wurde, bevor sie gegangen sind,
weil wir eben dort keine Möglichkeit hatten, eigene Industrien aufzubauen,
die dann eigenständig überlebensfähig wären.
Das heißt, der Kolonialismus hat auch die ökonomische Situation produziert,
in der heute Menschen in Kenia sagen, ich habe keine andere Möglichkeit,
als mich bei diesem Tech-Konzern zu verdingen. Das ist meine einzige Hoffnung.
Deshalb finde ich, kann man sie wirklich gar nicht trennen.
Ich finde, es hat auch noch eine Ebene, die man hinzunehmen muss.
Wenn du speziell nach diesem digitalen Kolonialismus fragst,
dann muss man sich natürlich auch fragen, wie sind die Konditionen,
dass bestimmte Staaten des globalen Nordens technische Innovationen durchdrücken.
Also einmal ist es natürlich…
Wer schafft diese Innovationen? Mit welcher Wirtschaftsmacht wird die anderswo sozusagen deployed?
Und da ist natürlich auch eine Folge des Kolonialismus letztlich,
wer da, welches Bildungssystem hat, wer welche Möglichkeiten für technische
Innovationen, welche Vormachtstellung.
Also das könnte man übertragen von anderen Wirtschaftsbereichen,
aber das finde ich in der Technik besonders ausgeprägt.
Und wenn man sich ein bisschen anguckt, welche technischen, ich will es ja nicht
immer Innovationen nennen, weil Innovationen ist irgendwie so ein neoliberaler
Begriff, aber ihr wisst, was ich meine, werden wohin exportiert?
Da kannst du natürlich genau wieder nachvollziehen, wer da die Macht in den
Händen hat und damit aber auch Leute wieder in Abhängigkeit bringt.
Ich wollte gerade nach der digitalen Infrastruktur nochmal fragen,
weil also jetzt von dem, was Ingo gerade gesagt hat,
habe ich mir jetzt, während ich dir das alles erzählt habe, schon gedacht,
ja Moment mal, wenn die sozusagen, also wenn Softwarekolonialismus,
dann brauchen die ja zumindest digitale Infrastruktur, also hinter der Zugang etc.
Und wenn man sich dann die Kolonialgeschichte anguckt, also ich so mit meinem
gefährlichen Halbwissen würde ich denken, dann würde man die aber wahrscheinlich
so bauen, wie du es gerade gesagt hast.
Das Analogon zu, wie bewegen wir am besten Truppen und Rohstoffen raus,
also das aber als Breitbandausbau.
Ist das auch Beobachter wahr und wenn ja, wie sieht das aus?
Naja, zum Beispiel, wenn man sich die weltweite Verteilung von Datenzentren
anguckt, Rechenzentren, wo die Daten gespeichert werden, die stehen fast alle im globalen Norden.
Auf dem afrikanischen Kontinent gibt es sehr wenige beispielsweise.
Das heißt, selbst wenn dort sozusagen Unterseekabel verlegt werden,
es eine Internetanbindung gibt, sozusagen Datenleitung gibt,
führt es ja dazu, dass die Daten, die haben wir jetzt noch so gut wie noch gar
nicht drüber gesprochen heute,
sozusagen die Rolle des Datenextraktivismus, dass die Daten dann aber nicht
im globalen Süden werden sie erzeugt und verarbeitet, aber dann werden erzeugt
und dann sozusagen verarbeitet.
Gespeichert, verarbeitet, in Wert gesetzt im globalen Norden,
weil dort die Rechenzentren stehen beispielsweise und weil es auch eine politische
sozusagen Bewegung gibt, der wiederum stark geprägt von der EU,
von den USA, teilweise auch von China,
dass man Datenlokalisierung verhindern möchte.
Also es gibt Länder wie Indien, Nigeria, die sagen, wir wollen eigentlich Gesetze
erlassen oder haben teilweise auch solche Gesetze erlassen, dass Daten im Land
gespeichert werden müssen, damit sie dort verarbeitet werden,
damit es auch dort eine Industrie entstehen kann.
Und das wird unter dem Schlagwort Free Flow of Data im Rahmen der WTO beispielsweise
versucht zu verhindern, dass man das verbietet.
So, das ist eine Bestrebung gewesen.
Ich muss ehrlich sagen, ich war jetzt gar nicht auf eine wirtschaftliche,
also sagen auch interessant.
Ich bin jetzt ein bisschen überrascht, dass es das dann auch noch gibt.
Das ist ja sozusagen Daten, das neue Öl, war ja immer so ein belächelter Vergleich,
aber hier scheint es so ein bisschen zu passen.
Ich dachte eher an sowas wie, also wirklich ganz praktisch sowas wie,
also doch Internet ausbauen.
Ich will jetzt nicht breitband aus Internet ausbauen, weil da gibt es ja so,
da haben wir ja hier im globalen Norden für so Dinge gekämpft,
also Routerzwang, irgendwie Netzneutralität.
Ich hatte noch was drittes, aber wir haben eine bestimmte Forschung davon entwickelt,
wie Internetzugang auszusehen hat, dass der möglichst jedem zur Verfügung steht,
dass die Betreiber nicht mit den AnschlussinhaberInnen machen können,
was sie wollen und so weiter und so fort.
Das meinte ich sozusagen. Also gibt es sowas auch, dass also Dinge,
die wir hier selbstverständlich in der Internetnutzung haben,
dass es die da nicht gibt, weil man eben auch wieder auf einer Gesellschaft
trifft, die sich schlecht wehren kann?
Man kann sich mal die Karten ansehen, wenn man etwa die Infrastruktur mal ganz
plastisch sehen will, wo liegen Breitbandkabel, Unterseekabel.
Guckt man sich da die Weltkarte an, dann sieht man sozusagen genau die Abbildung des Reichtums.
Die liegen natürlich auch gerade so im Atlantik sehr viele und man sieht,
dass Unterseekabel halt um den asiatischen und den afrikanischen Kontinent seltener
werden. Das kann man gut sehen.
Ingo hat in seinem Buch auch einen Artikel generell, wer eigentlich heute die
Internetkabel baut. Traditionell wandelt ja Telcos.
Das hat ja eine lange Geschichte.
1850 oder so ist das erste Telegrafenkabel gelegt worden.
Und heute sind das nicht mehr so die klassischen Telcos, sondern heute baut
Big Tech und vermieden das auch zu ihren Bedingungen.
Da hat sich auch wieder was fortgesetzt. Aber generell, wenn man jetzt mal auf
die Kontinente guckt, über uns schreiten wir uns hier viel über Breitband und
Glasfaser ausbauen. Wir wissen, in Deutschland sind wir nicht so gut dran.
Aber anderswo findet diese Diskussion so gar nicht statt. Also wenn man sich
den afrikanischen Kontinent ansieht, dann sieht man sehr deutlich,
dass da viel, viel, viel mehr über Mobilfunk funktioniert als hier.
Das ist also eine Infrastruktur, wie wir die hier kennen, so Breitband bis überall,
was ja auch eine Möglichkeit ist, jenseits von der Tech-Branche,
aber ist natürlich auch immer wichtig für alle mittlerweile Wirtschaftszweige,
findet da so gar nicht statt.
Und bei der Netzneutralität, sag du mal Inge, du hast ja, oder man könnte natürlich
noch andere Beispiele nehmen.
Ich wollte nochmal auf eine Ambivalenz hinweisen, die sich da gerade ergibt,
weil wir jetzt gerade in der Situation sehen, dass sich seit einigen Jahren
die Tech-Konzerne aus den USA, Big Tech, aufspielen als diejenigen,
die jetzt die Konnektivität bringen.
Also die in Meta baut das erste Unterseekabel, das den gesamten afrikanischen Kontinent umfasst.
Auch Google sozusagen hat große Unterseekabelprojekte zu Afrika und die sagen
natürlich zum afrikanischen Kontinent und die sagen natürlich,
toll, wir schließen euch an, Konnektivität, wir bringen euch Wirtschaftswachstum.
So ein bisschen auch da eine gewisse Kolonialismus-Metapher,
weil das so alles, auch das gab es ja im Kolonialismus sehr stark,
das Labeln der eigenen wirtschaftlichen Interessen und der eigenen Eroberung
so als zivilisatorische Mission.
Man bringt jetzt sozusagen die Zivilisation und so ein bisschen spiegelt sich
das da auch wieder und das ist natürlich sehr ambivalent, weil einerseits
haben, Deswegen ist es, wie Konstanze gerade beschrieben hat,
es gibt dort große Konnektivitätslücken auf dem afrikanischen Kontinent,
auch sehr unterschiedlich je nach Land und Region, darf man auch immer nicht
als alles eins behandeln, aber es ist gleichzeitig so, dass das natürlich dann
eine Konnektivität zu den Bedingungen von Big Tech ist.
Ja, deren Kalkül dahinter ist, okay, wir wollen die nächste Milliarde anschließen.
Wer die nächste Milliarde NutzerInnen ans Internet anschließt,
der kriegt die nächste Milliarde NutzerInnen für seine eigenen sozialen Netzwerke.
Facebook hatte, Meta hatte, als es noch Facebook hieß, der Konzern,
das Free Basics Modell, wo sie in Ländern überwiegend des globalen Südens kostenlosen
Internetzugang gewährt hat, die,
Aber Internetzugang nur das, was der Konzern definiert hat, als das, was das Internet ist.
Also natürlich zum Beispiel Facebook konnte man dann umsonst nutzen mit Facebook.
Facebook und WhatsApp.
Genau, WhatsApp auch. Ein paar Dinge irgendwann haben sie dann auf Wikipedia
dazu gepackt oder so. Aber zum Beispiel fast ausschließlich englischsprachige Dienste und Websites.
Kaum Inhalte in lokalen Sprachen.
Übrigens auch keine in chinesischen, also in Mandarin oder so.
Also es war schon sehr, sehr westlich, also englisch-westlich geprägt.
Die Kritik war übrigens westlich.
Im Westen gab es daran viel Kritik. Viele NGOs haben sich stark gemacht,
dass diese Verträge ja wohl gar nicht gehen und auch von der Netzneutralität inakzeptabel sind.
Aber tatsächlich waren sie ziemliche Schlager. Also, muss man ja auch mal sagen.
Für eine Weile. Die ersten, die es gekippt haben, ist Indien gewesen durch eine
große zivilgesellschaftliche Kampagne, die sehr erfolgreich sozusagen das dann
unterbunden und verboten haben.
Meta hat das übrigens eingestellt inzwischen, weil sie es dann doch nicht gerechnet hat.
Aber man sieht jetzt Fortsetzungen davon eben in den Unterseekabeln.
Also da gab es ja auch noch ganz interessante, müssen wir jetzt hier nicht vertiefen,
aber Google wollte irgendwie mit Heißluftballons Internet in entlegene Regionen
bringen. Auch Südamerika.
Jetzt ham wir Starlink.
Genau, und jetzt haben wir eben Starlink. Also Elon Musk und Amazon mit dem
Projekt Kulpa in einer kleineren Dimension bislang versuchen das jetzt gerade
auch mit der gleichen Rhetorik.
Wir schließen die Welt an, wir bringen das Internet in die Regionen,
die es sonst nicht haben.
Aber natürlich bauen sie damit eine komplette, also das Internet aus dem Weltall,
sehr fasziniertes Thema, bauen damit eine eigene Internetinfrastruktur auf,
die alleine von ihnen beherrscht wird, die kaum reguliert ist,
weil es da keine transnationale Regulierung gibt, die komplett nach ihrem sozusagen
Gutdünken funktioniert.
Und diese Abhängigkeit kann dann eben auch wieder zu Problemen führen für staatliche
Souveränität oder auch für diese Bevölkerungen, wie beispielsweise der Konflikt
in Brasilien gezeigt hat,
wo Elon Musk im Prinzip damit gedroht hat, diese Konnektivität,
die über Starlink sich ausgebreitet hatte, zurückzunehmen, als Ex für eine Zeit
lang verboten wurde in Brasilien durch einen Richter.
Und da zeigt sich dann eben auch wieder die zwei Seiten dieses Infrastrukturangebots.
Das hängt überhaupt nicht zusammen, muss man sich ja auch mal klar machen.
Auch ein vollständiger anderer Teil von dir besitzt über einen von Elon Musk.
Zwei verschiedene Unternehmen.
Vielleicht waren Multimilliardäre doch ein Fehler.
Ich finde, wenn wir auf die Endrunde einbinden können, das eine,
was man glaube ich mitnehmen muss, ist, dass nichts…
Also eine Ausnahme bestätigen die Regeln und so, aber nichts,
was wir digital benutzen, ist frei von digitalem Kolonismus,
würde ich jetzt mal so vermuten zumindest. Das ist die unangenehme Wahrheit.
Das ist auf jeden Fall eine Wahrheit, ja.
Ja. Der man sich stellen muss, weil man jetzt nicht alles von Hand gestrickt
hat und selbst dann läuft es auf Geräten, die wahrscheinlich vergiftet sind.
Im Prinzip bist du jetzt schon erfolgreich in eine postkoloniale Perspektive
eingetreten, denn wenn man diese Brille aufsetzt, dann ist die Welt einfach
kolonial strukturiert in jeder Hinsicht.
Dann sieht man Rassismus im Alltag und Ausbeutung im Alltag hier und insbesondere
in den globalen Beziehungen.
Was ich aber ganz spannend finde an dieser Debatte ist, dass sie ein Stück weit
den Fokus auch wieder lenkt auf die Binnenbeziehungen in den Gesellschaften
des globalen Nordens oder der globalen Minorität.
Es gibt ja auch quasi, spricht man heutzutage gar nicht mehr unbedingt vom globalen
Norden und dem globalen Süden, sondern der globale Süden bezeichnet sich als die globale Mehrheit.
Das sind nämlich tatsächlich ja numerisch viele Menschen und der globale Norden
ist die globale Minderheit.
Auch zurück den Blick auf die globale Minderheit und die Frage,
was können wir hier eigentlich tun.
Und das Spannende ist, dass dann entsprechend Ausbeutungsstrukturen,
die wir insbesondere sehen, wenn wir auf Nord-Süd-Beziehungen blicken,
sich dann aber auch im Norden wieder zeigen.
Also Nicodri und Ulysses Mechias sind zwei Wissenschaftler, die viel zu Datenkolonialismus
und digitalem Kolonialismus gearbeitet haben in den letzten Jahren,
für ein Argument, das sehr, sehr kontrovers diskutiert wird, die aber sagen,
im Prinzip werden auch Nutzerinnen und Nutzer überall kolonial ausgebeutet durch
die Art und Weise, wie sie eben ihre Daten hergeben müssen, wie sie ihnen entrissen
werden und auch andere ausbeuterische Beziehungen.
Und so sehr das diskutiert wird, ob hier diese Metapher reicht oder nicht und
ob man das als kolonial bezeichnen kann oder nicht, ist es glaube ich doch ganz
spannend, weil es eben wiederum insgesamt den Blick schärft auf ausbeuterische
Beziehungen und Möglichkeiten für Widerstand.
Und da denke ich, kann so eine Perspektive eben auch produktiv sein für die
Art und Weise, wie wir uns hier damit auseinandersetzen.
Ich bin so ein bisschen skeptisch bei diesem engen Anwendung des Kolonialismusbegriffs
auf das, was sozusagen Tech-Konzernen mit uns auch im globalen Norden machen,
weil es eben leicht dazu führt, das würde ich Kolder und Megias auch vorwerfen,
dass es sozusagen dann doch nur um die Probleme sozusagen…
Es relativiert, ne?
Genau, es relativiert so ein bisschen, droht zur Metapher zu verkommen,
während wir gleichzeitig noch einen sozusagen sehen, wie wir den klassischen
Kolonialismus und seine Auswirkungen gerade entlang der Nord-Süd-Machtmatrix
sozusagen weiter erleben, das worüber wir heute gesprochen haben.
Deshalb Also ihr beide führt gerade eine Diskussion zu sagen,
in der man glaube ich sehr tief drinstecken muss, um die führen zu können.
Mein erster Eindruck ist, dass es vielleicht sozusagen den Punkt haben könnte
im Sinne von diese Machtstrukturen, die die Mächtigen ausnutzen,
werden sich wahrscheinlich, wenn sie die Wahl haben, nicht nur auf die beschränken,
die man historisch schon immer ausgenutzt hat, sondern die werden auch alle
anderen mitnehmen, die sie ausnutzen können.
Aber, apropos Widerstand, was kann man denn besser machen?
Vielleicht um nochmal aufzuzeigen, was spannend ist oder auch innovativ im besten
Sinne an der postkolonialen Perspektive ist eine radikale Entnormalisierung
von Ausbeutung, die uns schockieren sollte.
Und das ist eine Perspektive, die man auf ganz viel anwenden kann.
Und unsere Gesellschaften sind ständig damit beschäftigt zu normalisieren.
Wir normalisieren alles mögliche, was nicht normal sein sollte.
Und das ist im Prinzip die umgekehrte Perspektive, wie sehr wir uns schockieren
lassen von den Dingen und entsprechend dann Regulierung fordern, Widerstand leisten.
Und in vielen Regionen, von denen wir eben gesprochen haben,
beispielsweise gibt es durchaus Gesetzesprojekte, dass Datenschutzgesetze überhaupt
erstmal geschrieben und umgesetzt werden.
Und ja, das ist, denke ich, ein Kampf, der währt schon länger,
aber der wird hoffentlich auch nicht erschlaffen.
Ganz konkrete Solidarität auch üben, also da sind wir jetzt gerade eben schon
so drüber weggekommen, aber es
gibt beispielsweise in Nairobi gerade sehr interessante Gerichtsverfahren,
die Content-ModeratorInnen angestrengt haben gegen Meta und die Outsourcing-Firma Sama,
teilweise auch unterstützt von der britischen NGO Foxglove Legal und auch sozusagen,
wo auch aus Deutschland das Superlab beispielsweise mit unterstützt,
also NGOs aus dem globalen Norden, die sozusagen dann eine sozusagen Solidarität
und praktische Solidarität auch üben.
Ganz interessantes Gerichtsverfahren, das läuft übrigens noch und ein vorläufiger,
das ist auch so ein bisschen was mir Hoffnung gibt durchaus an manchen Stellen,
das Gericht in Kenia hat festgestellt, Facebook darf nicht sagen,
nö wieso, wir sind ja gar nicht die Arbeitgeber von denen, die Outstourcingfirma
ist ja der Arbeitgeber, wir tragen keine Verantwortung.
Das heißt, es gibt da auf jeden Fall ja auch Prozesse.
Konstanze hat es angesprochen, sozusagen die ArbeiterInnen fangen an,
sich auszutauschen, gewirtschaftlich sich zu organisieren, mit einer Stimme zu sprechen.
Das sind auf jeden Fall Prozesse, die man unterstützen kann,
die wir hier unterstützen können, wo wir Solidarität üben.
Na, mehr noch. Also kann man ja noch generalisieren. Also A,
wir müssen mal drüber reden.
Also das tun wir gerade hier und ich finde, es gibt auch eine Zunahme.
Also auch so journalistische Projekte, Podcast, Radio, Bücher,
da gibt es eine Menge, aber wir müssen es halt auch wahrnehmen.
Und diese Abstumpfung, von der du sprichst, gegen die muss man sich relativ aktiv wehren.
In allen anderen Bereichen auch. Ich würde jetzt nicht nur hier vorzählen,
aber ich glaube, da sind wir dran. Und wir sind reich. Verzeihung.
Es geht ja auch oft um Geld. Man kann irgendwie spenden.
Und da gibt es viele tolle Zwecke für die Bad Spendengarten, keine Frage.
Und dann muss man, finde ich, konkrete politische Forderungen draus machen,
wie bei allen anderen Bereichen.
Na klar, wenn man sich jetzt die verschiedenen Wahlprogramme angeht,
bei uns ist ja jetzt bald wieder Wahlkammer schon sehr unterschiedliche Ansätze
sehen, etwa was Recycling angeht oder Lieferketten.
Da muss man aber auch mal drauf schauen, finde ich. Nun haben wir eh immer Schwierigkeiten
hier in Deutschland, ein anderes Thema im Wahlkampf als, naja,
ihr wisst schon, zu besprechen.
Aber ich finde, man muss es auch zu konkreten politischen Forderungen machen
und nicht individualisieren. Wir hatten ja vorhin schon die...
Und die Lupe auf Unternehmen, die vielleicht gar nicht so bekannt sind.
Oh ja, das ist auch wichtig. Das stimmt, ja. Du hast ja gerade schon irgendwelche,
also Ingo hat gerade welche genannt, die sind jetzt bekannt,
wegen einer großen Medien-Story.
Die können welche in die Shownotes schreiben. Ja, genau.
Genau, jetzt haben wir hier eine reichliche Stunde zusammengesessen und sozusagen
ersten Einblick in dieses Thema gehabt und das ist noch längst nicht alles.
Deswegen können wir vielleicht eine Abschlussrunde machen mit,
wo kann man, wenn man jetzt nach der Stunde noch Bock hat, irgendwie noch mehr
darüber zu wissen, wo kann man anfangen.
Ich vermute, ein gewisser Herr Dachwitz würde ein Buch empfehlen,
das Digitaler Kolonismus heißt.
Ich hatte mich gerade gemeldet, aber genau um das nicht zu sagen,
sondern um deutlich zu machen, also ich finde es Genau, sich zu bilden,
Bewusstsein zu schaffen, ist total wichtig.
Wir hoffen, dass wir mit unserem Buch einen Teil dazu beitragen können in der
deutschen Öffentlichkeit, aber es ist uns eben auch ganz klar wichtig zu sagen,
das ist nichts, was wir erfunden haben, das ist keine Kritik,
die sozusagen, die auch nur annähernd sozusagen neu ist, sondern die vor allen
Dingen von ForscherInnen, AktivistInnen, Nichtregierungsorganisationen aus dem
globalen Süden, ja schon seit langem kommt so.
Ich verstehe, was du sagen willst, aber man kann dein Buch sozusagen trotzdem
gut lesen, um Einstieg zu finden,
Oder? Das stimmt, ich will nur trotzdem einmal, wir sind zwei weiße Autoren
aus dem globalen Norden, zwei Männer noch dazu, das heißt, das ist uns absolut
wichtig gewesen im Buch, dass wir diese Stimmen, die ich eben nannte,
im Buch auch hören, wiedergeben,
auch dass es nicht frei von Machtdynamiken und so, aber genau,
das ist mir wichtig und da gibt es eben,
Es gibt beispielsweise Michael Quett, südafrikanischer Politikwissenschaftler,
der seit langem zu digitalem Kolonialismus veröffentlicht. Es gibt diverse Studien.
Ich brauche sie hier wahrscheinlich gar nicht alle aufzuzählen.
Ich gehe dir darum, für die interessierten Menschen einen Anknüpfungspunkt zu finden.
Weil wenn ihr jetzt alle drei Quellen sagt, dann ist es schon wieder Optionsparalyse.
Aber der Buch ist in deutscher Sprache. Da gibt es nicht so viel.
Ja, stimmt. Ich glaube, Marcus versucht in so einer Abschlussrunde.
Dann schreiben wir noch ein paar Dinge in die Shownotes. Ansonsten empfehle
ich noch die Arbeit, aber das mache ich jetzt schon, auch noch von Renata Avila,
die auch das Nachwort geschrieben hat für unser Buch,
in dem sie auch nochmal deutlich macht, dass wir die Systemfrage wirklich stellen müssen sozusagen.
Sagen, wir brauchen, wir müssen an der Zukunft ganz konkret arbeiten,
die sozusagen weg geht von Big Tech, ein anderes Wirtschaften sozusagen hin
zu kooperativen, genossenschaftlichen Modellen, andere Formen der Tech-Regulierung,
weg von diesem One-Size-Fits-All-Ansatz.
So, das heißt, auch das kann ich nochmal sehr empfehlen, um die großen Systemfragen,
die wir ändern müssen, anzugehen.
Okay, Lena, ein Literaturtipp von dir.
Gerne. Also, meine beiden sind englischsprachig. Das eine wäre ein Podcast,
in dem ich Co-Host bin, Purple Code, das sind intersektional-feministische Perspektiven
auf die digitale Transformation und unsere Gäste sind alles Gender Dissidenzen oder Frauen,
die eben einen eigenen Blick haben auf die Tech-Welt und darüber hinaus auch ein Blog,
der fantastisch ist, der heißt Rest of World,
kommt in die Shownotes und da gibt es Newsletter und man bekommt eine Menge
Tech-News und auch über die ganzen politischen Bewegungen drumherum überall auf der Welt.
Von Regionen, von denen man sonst nicht viel liest.
Conz?
Ich würde vielleicht was ganz Konkretes empfehlen. Ich habe da heute erst reingehört,
denn Lena hat beim Camp vom CCC im Sommer einen Vortrag gehalten.
Ich habe nur den Anfang gehört, aber ich weiß schon, wo jemand bei Ingo hat
es auf der Herfahrt gehört. Ein sehr guter Vortrag.
Es ist einfach ein super Einblick. Wir haben bei Media CCC alle Vorträge von
den CCC-Veranstaltungen.
Wir haben tatsächlich eine ganze Menge, die würde ich auch nochmal zusammenstellen für die Shownotes.
Also ich finde es lohnt sich, Leute, die sich damit beschäftigen,
anzuhören. Und wir zumindest beim CCC haben eine ganze Menge davon.
Und der Camp-Vortrag von Lena wäre ein guter Beginn, wenn er ein guter Überleg ist.
Wie auch immer, in welchem Format ihr euch dem Thema nähern wollt,
Podcast, Newsletter, Video, Buch, alles da.
Ihr habt also genug zu tun. Ingo, Lena, Konz, vielen Dank, dass ihr da wart.
Danke, Marcus.
Liebe HörerInnen, viel Spaß. Obwohl das ein bisschen beklemmend ist,
das bei diesem Thema zu sagen.
Und natürlich, wie immer, lasst euch nicht überwachen und verschlüsselt immer
schön eure Backups. Tschüss.